[Music]  yes  well when i was a little girl in in  slave day  i always had something to do every day  every day  i didn't have time to play very much  at all  i myself  was in the house for most of the time  and days like this  while we were outdoors  pulling up weeds  or picking up feathers where sicknesses  all make  them through the yard  or every day  and then cloudy days while we were in  the house  they had a big pan of plain  silver fan and an old slipper scrubbing  up the floor  in the big dining room where they ate  the meal  mr henry where did you live as a slave  i was saved over life  where did you live  i'm truly there for his wife  where did he live before washington  i told you  [Music]